- So you also started pole dancing.
- Yes I did.
- I remember you talking
about this.
So how are the lessons going?
- The lessons are going
slow, but they're going.
(Kelly clapping)
- It's hard!
- Cause, you know I have
Well Danielle Hawkins, who
was also my pole dancer.
She also pole dances with
skates on, by the way.
- Yeah
- but she always,
the moves that she has me doing,
I'm like, "Girl, I got arthritis
in that part of my leg."
(Kelly laughing)
- inflammation
- Thank you, the inflammation.
But she'll say, "Now we're
going to bring our legs up,"
and I go, "With what muscles?
Ab muscles?
I ain't got that."
(Kelly laughing)
So, I'm going through,
but it works your abs,
your core,
- Yeah.
- Your arms, your thigh
- Muscles you didn't even
know you had.
- Muscles you didn't even know you had.
- Dude, I tried once
at this hotel randomly,
it had a pole in it.
Look, it was a bunch of people,
it wasn't freaky like that,
but there's nothing wrong with it
if you wanna be freaky like that.
(Sherry laughing)
But I just mean,
(Kelly stuttering)
the loudest, it was just like,
it was like, and this
was when I was in shape
- Uh huh.
- and I got on it and just boof.
- Fell right to the floor.
- I was like wait, what?
I was like, that's really hard.
- You tried too hard.
I'm gonna tell you,
I went and did a movie in
Vancouver for Lifetime.
And I brought, you can
take the pole with you.
I have a pole in my bedroom.
- Wait, it's a travel pole?
- Yes, it's travel pole.
I have it in my bedroom.
Jeffrey came in the room and he said,
"I wouldn't have my daughter doing this."
And I was just like, "What?"
So this is in Canada, but
I didn't put it up right,
and so the asbestos all
fell from the ceiling
in my mouth,
- OH!
- but it was so funny to
see the Canadian police,
cause they were like, "What is this?"
And I said, "It's my pole."
And they said, "What are you?
What is it for?"
And I said, "It's when I dance"
and they go, "Why are you here?"
I said, "I'm doing a movie."
So I think they thought
I was doing a porno.
It was all right.
- Oh my God.
Oh my God.
I love that explanation to
people showing up at your door.
- Yeah, I just "It's my dance pole."
- It's amazing.